Nationwide reading and math scores
declined during the covid-19 pandemic
according to the National Center for
Education statistics but Henderson
libraries they're really hoping to turn
a new page and inspire a love of reading
for kids Good Day Las Vegas reporter
Laura negretti takes us into the library
for a reading challenge
a mission for kindergarten through fifth
graders 500 books before Middle School
seven-year-old Finn Holmes already read
210 books he likes to meet goals he's
ready for me they weren't ready for him
the Holmes family comes in Weekly The
Challenge debuted at the end of February
Library staff hope it brings more
regulars anything we can do to encourage
more readers starts to boost test scores
it starts to boost math and reading and
science it just it helps everything
those subjects declined during the
pandemic the Holmes family home schools
and focuses on reading absolutely it
helps his vocabulary has grown
tremendously two books a week comes out
to 104 a year similar to their summer
reading program kids and parents can
track their progress online or through
their beanstack app kids earn a prize
every 50 books read a dog tag chain and
charms they get a free book from the
friends of Henderson library's book sale
when they complete the challenge a new
chapter for encouraging literacy in
Henderson Lauren negretti 8 News Now
and you can sign up for the challenge on
the Henderson library's website we have
a link for you at 8newsnow.com